[siren blaring]
Oh, hey.
What you got there?
Uh, yeah, uh...noth--
It's little a Blu-ray,
Blu-ray disk system.
- Blu-ray disk system, huh?
- Yeah, you know.
Yeah, is it worth going
to jail for that?
For a $700 DVD player?
Seven hundred dollars?
No, man.
They dropped these down to,
like, 250, 269 right now.
- No!
- Oh, yeah.
This is cheap as hell.
Now, if I watch
Blu-rays on my tube...
...is it gonna have letterbox
or is it gonna be full
frame like standard?
If you, wha-what
you asked for was a 16x9...
- Hey, guys.
- ...or 4x3.
- I do not know.
- Hello, officer.
- Hi.
- Hey.
- What you got there?
- Oh, a little Blu-ray player.
- Blu-ray player.
- Brand-new Blu-ray player.
Oh, a Blu-ray player.
- Hey, I got a question.
- Yeah.
Do those things play
on plasmas or just CRTs?
No, no, these play
on plasma, CRTs, DLPs...
- He says--
- LCDs.
Any kind of
format you have.
How much did you pay
for that one right there?
- Oh, this one right here?
- Yeah.
Oh, this was free for me.
I stole it.
Uh!
- Hey, junior?
- Yeah?
You still got that
8-track tape player?
Yeah. I don't think those will
work on a Blu-ray, though.
Oh...[bleep]